hi there
welcome to another episode of q a
about history of science and technology
i'm happy to try and talk about both
things that i've been involved in myself
and things i might have studied i have
to say i've been i'm in the middle of a
of a kind of a
difficult history project right now that
i thought was going to be really easy
history project it's
soon going to be the 20th anniversary of
my big book a new kind of science the
publication of that book
on may 14th uh 2022 will be the 20th
anniversary of the original publication
of that book and i thought it would be
interesting
to go and write a little bit about
almost the anecdotes associated with the
making of that book i thought this was
going to be easy because i thought hey
this was something i did myself
starting about 30 years ago in 1991
um
and uh
it's turned out to be a lot harder than
i thought and it kind of reminds one of
the following fact
that when one
lives through events and does things one
is not forming the thoughts at that time
of what the kind of arc of history that
connects those events will be
and and so there are things where i did
this i did this i did this but then if
you look at it
zoomed out a bit you can kind of see
well that's what led to this or that
happening
um and uh but i hadn't really formed the
thoughts that that's how things sort of
were strung together back when i was
just doing them so to speak so i've been
trying to reconstruct uh for example how
it was that i went from in 1991 the idea
that i would write a small book that
would be kind of a an exposition and
condensation of work that i'd done
mostly in the 1980s mostly towards
answering the question sort of how does
that come to be complexity in nature how
did i go from that to writing the 1280
page book that is a new kind of science
that really has a much bigger
uh kind of story than this original
question about sort of the origins of
complexity which i think it it manages
to handily dispatch that question and
then goes on to the much broader kinds
of issues that uh
eventually gave the book the title a new
kind of science
so in any case i've been i've been
trying to trace down all those things
and a lot of that has also
turned out to be uh the um
a lot of elaborate
history of technology
that uh
sort of was very entangled with what
made it possible to produce the new kind
of science book um in the end
things even to do with printing
technology and the possibility of making
very high resolution images of of things
like cellular automata with sort of
where every pixel counts and so on and
having that be crisp that required all
kinds of printing technology issues that
um i was also
way too deeply involved in around 2001
and 2002.
anyway it's something i've been trying
to write and it's also required going
back
and have most of the
material
uh just to give some sense of sort of
history on the ground
um
you know i have kind of the final files
that were used for producing the book i
even have a virtual machine that is the
actual book production software as of
2002 um all preserved and able to be run
as a virtual machine at some kind of
windows machine
brought back to life with very crowded
looking ux i have to say
um
then
i have files and i have mostly the
latest versions of all the files that we
use to create the book and all the
programs that we use to create the book
earlier versions are on tapes
and uh those tapes still have
um and we've been restoring some of
those tapes a little bit of a challenge
to find a tape drive that will read
eight millimeter video tape that was
what was used as backup a backup medium
um and it's a little confusing and the
late tapes are not as well labeled as
they should have been
back 30 years ago
but uh we've been slowly restoring some
of those tapes and able to see uh files
and they're just all kinds of remarkable
things that i find
one of the things that's very striking
to me
looking for example at email that i sent
30 years ago i have that all archived
back to 1989 actually um i have all my
sent and received email archived uh okay
there's some footnotes to that like
i was using a next computer which had a
very beautiful attachments mechanism for
email but unfortunately the archiver
decided to get rid of the attachments
because on the grounds that they were
too big and bulky and so on and so those
attachments have to be hunted down
separately
but um
the uh the thing that is sort of
remarkable about reading email that one
wrote 30 years ago
is uh you know i i feel pretty pretty
satisfied that the things i wrote were
quite sensible um and uh
but every story
that one is describing and just and
being part of in those emails is pretty
much the end of the story is now known
30 years later
there are all kinds of interactions with
people and interactions with
organizations and so on and on and kind
of knows the end of those stories
um and that's been quite interesting to
me to try and sort of uh
understand the the more of the arc of
what's happened there i think an awful
lot of the emails
were
uh to do with building our products and
things
and building
well from language and all that kind of
thing and it is very satisfying to see
that there were you know particular
bricks being put into the cathedral so
to speak back in 1991 and yep that brick
is still there and it's still holding up
some some piece of of what's been built
on top of it that's a that's a a nice
thing to realize that when one wasn't
wasting one's time and just building a
structure that that uh all got torn down
in the intervening years no those are
bricks that are part of a large
structure that got built up
but in any case that that's um uh been i
was going to say about other raw
material um there's uh you know the
online the the archives of email and
archives of files backup tapes
um i also
have physical pieces of paper um that i
uh
wrote things on and and printouts and so
on uh at least from 1993 onward um those
have not been scanned and those are uh
and that that's the thing that i'm about
to start looking through
um it's kind of interesting
archaeological exercise because in order
to kind of um uh define the i knew that
i was making sort of archaeological
layers in order to make sure i had date
markers in there i would throw in things
like the uh the phone list from our
company or random pieces of uh of of
material that were dated in one way or
another and so that's kind of a a place
where one gets to see sort of things of
the time um embedded in all kinds of
notes and so on many of those notes are
almost timeless that you know whatever
they might be printouts or pictures of
touring machines or something like this
um and those would look well they would
look better today just because they're
high resolution um but uh
not um uh not necessarily um
um
uh anything else
um
the uh
so
the thing that um
um
so trying to go through those things
it's um
uh i was going to say another thing that
i've been finding is photographs
and there are photographs that were both
taken
for the construction of the book itself
and there are lots that didn't make it
into the final book
um there are lots of strange photographs
of all kinds of things
that were intended as examples of
complexity nature things like this
didn't make the cut into the final book
those are interesting to see they're
mostly black and white photographs
mostly what's in my archives is the
contact sheets
from the negatives you know just printed
directly as little one inch square
things or whatever one inch across
things
um it is a little frustrating that
whereas in modern times when all sort of
photographers or you know practice is
digital um and one can you know one has
lots and lots of pictures i might go
find them they're things that i really
want to find from 1991 that i know there
are pictures of um i just can't find
them
and uh sort of because i didn't have an
organized archiving scheme for
photographs it didn't take that many
photographs and when i did they were
just you know negatives and little
little folders of uh of of little you
know printed photographs so to speak um
so anyway i'm still searching for some
of those things hoping to to find them
uh for my makeup nks um
my essay about that
um
let's
see uh questions here
oh there's a pretty technical one here
from communities about the history of
dimensional regularization and zeta
regularization how are they related to
renalization okay well this let me i'll
try and address this a little bit it's
um
one of the awkward things
in physics is if we think an electron is
a
is a kind of a geometrical point
there are lots of things that one might
compute about it that are infinite it's
of zero size but that means that for
example its electric potential its one
over r type um
potential is infinite right at the
electron itself and you might say oh
that problem is going to go away when
you do quantum mechanics and quantum
electrodynamics and so on but it doesn't
go away there are still infinities when
you do
the integrals and things to compute for
example the self-energy of an electron
how much what the uh
energy associated with an electron uh
basically um having uh electromagnetic
interactions emitting and reabsorbing
virtual photons to itself if the
electron is of zero size
then those integrals diverge
those integrals are usually given in
momentum space so you're doing an
integral over all momenta of some
particular quantity and that integral um
has divergences in it
um so
and those but those divergences have the
property that
uh they they only diverge
in well in four dimensional space
they they diverge
but if you are in uh
lower dimensional space
they do not diverge
um and so
what
you can do is say well imagine i was in
four dimensional space well no actually
let me be in four minus epsilon
dimensional space
and let me do the integrals in four
minus epsilon dimensional space instead
of four dimensional space
and then uh then i can compute them and
they're finite and i'll get some results
which have
uh which are functions of epsilon so
they might have a term one over epsilon
squared plus
you know one over epsilon plus three
plus something else
and then so the the when epsilon goes to
zero corresponding to exact four
dimensional space those terms that are
like one over epsilon squared terms and
so on go to infinity but if you've got
several different things that you're
looking at
where they've all got a one over epsilon
squared term you can often and this is
sort of the trick of renaultization you
can often cancel the one over epsilon
squared terms and just look at the
finite pieces that get left over and
that gives you the actual values that
are relevant for doing experiments and
so on
so kind of the idea is let's just sort
of modify the effective dimension of
space
um do the computations which will then
be finite but depend on the deviation
for the direction of space from four
cancel out those terms which are now
terms we can sort of just pick up and
handle algebraically and look at what
the differences are
now when i say that one's doing these
things assuming a different number of
dimensions of space it's a very weak
version of doing that it's basically
just using the fact that we know the
volume of a sphere
in um uh
in d dimensional space and it's given by
something that's proportional to
r to the d
times some product of gamma functions
and things which in you know for a
circle it's pi r squared for a sphere
it's uh four thirds pi r cubed for a
hypersphere it's um what is it
four pi
squared uh times um uh r to the fourth
something like that for for a four
dimensional hypersphere and so on and it
keeps going um uh in different
dimensions
but that formula can be analytically
continued to an arbitrary d-dimensional
sphere and that's essentially what one's
using in doing these calculations in
particle physics and quantum electron
dynamics and so on uh with dimensional
regularization
now i i think
the um
uh
the pla first place where i know that
dimensional regularization was used was
a little report called diagrammer that
was written by teeny weltman and gerhard
hoft
back in
1976 i would say give or take
um it was a cern report
that um was trying to describe how to do
feynman diagram calculations and it was
sort of a a i think that was the place
where i certainly first saw a
dimensional regularization being used
um it became
more important to have sort of
streamlined feynman diagram calculating
techniques when one was doing them for
qcd for qed quantum electron dynamics
there had been particular things that
were computed you know the anomalous
magnetic moment of the electron the
various other kinds of scattering
processes and so on but those have
pretty much been computed by the 1940s
1950s 1960s those the the main
experimentally accessible versions of
those have been computed with the
exception of the enormous magnetic
moment of the electron monophthong
which was a very high precision
computation which went on being computed
higher higher precision um and that was
sort of a specialized activity for a
number of years but kind of the general
how do you roughly compute climate
diagrams the main feminine diagrams that
people have been interested in quantum
hydrodynamics have been computed um by
the 60s and so on uh but then quantum
chromodynamics came along the theory of
quarks and gluons and there's a whole
raft of new finding diagrams to be
computed there are also finding diagrams
to be computed in the in
what's now called the standard model
used to be called the weinberg salaam
model um the the model in which there
are w bosons and z bosons gauge bosons
in addition to the photon there were
computations to be done there um and uh
and there were also some toy field
theories like five-fourth field theory
by cube field theory where people did
some time and diagram computations
but so by the um by the late 70s there
was a need mid to late 70s there was a
need for sort of more streamlined
feynman diagram computing techniques and
dimensional regularization was the thing
that came out of that
the importance of dimensional
regularizations more of physics point is
that people have been using things like
explicit cutoffs where you say integrate
the momentum up to some value of the
momentum
doing that uh broke a relativistic and
variance and so caused one to have all
kinds of fancy footwork associated with
making sure that the results one got
would be relativistically invariant
dimensional regularization didn't have
that problem
and so
that was how that originated
um i myself used it quite a bit i was
quite an enthusiast of it um in the when
was that uh 1978-ish time frame um
actually one of the things that i had
figured out which a student who was
working with me um subsequently wrote up
uh but um i have been interested in okay
so we know about the volume of a whole
sphere
how do we think about
uh kind of um
how do we think about some
kind of angular dependence in d
dimensional space
and uh things called giganbar
polynomials which are generalizations of
the spherical harmonics
um spherical harmonics are the things
that give you you know those nice
orbitals and so on in chemistry they're
the three-dimensional well in in in two
dimensions there's sines and cosines are
the sort of orthogonal functions on on
intervals um in in three dimensions the
analogous sort of orthogonal functions
on the sphere of the spherical harmonics
that give you orbitals in chemistry the
question is what's the d dimensional
generalization of that and the answer is
gigan bar polynomials and so it's
possible to decompose a bunch of the
kinds of uh things that appear in fyman
diagrams and d dimensions into gegenbar
polynomials and there's a whole nice
theory of that that i started working
out and a
student who worked with me um ended up
i says back in probably 1979 1980 this
time frame um ended up finishing and
writing up and i think that's become
quite an industry in the in the years
since
but um uh that's that's a little bit on
on the theory of dimensional
regularization it's it's uh i in recent
times in our physics project we're
interested in these hypergraphs that
represent the low-level structure of
space and whose limit can correspond to
sort of ordinary space in d dimensions
where d is not necessarily determined to
be certainly not three and not even an
integer and so it's of interest to
understand how things work
in in space that isn't
uh interdimensional but that's actually
quite complicated and much more
difficult than the case of dimensional
regularization which is mostly these
these you know volumes of spheres or
sort of uh
easy angular dependence and spheres that
that shows up
um
let's see
there's a question here
from aaron about when and how was the
first compiler made what language was it
for what language was it written in
um if i know that history correctly
uh the first
compilers were for fortran and then
cobol
and they were written um around
1958 i think
uh
the
fortran the name
stood for formula translation
and
what had been done previously
is when you program the computer you
were using the machine code of the
computer and you were telling the
computer to you know
sort of open you know turn this gate
this way do this thing with this
accumulator you're really telling it
step by step in ter in its terms you
know do things with this particular
piece of the computer's hardware
and that was how you did a computation
kind of the idea and this was an idea i
think ibm was much involved with
the
the idea of formula translation where
you would write down something that
looked like a mathematical formula and
it will be translated into that set of
operations that say you know send data
from this
from this accumulator to that register
and do this operation on it and so on it
was a way of translating something that
looked like a formula into those machine
code operations and that was kind of the
origination of 4chan now i assume that
the fortran compiler was written in
machine code
there were
there was some let's see there was a
thing
called auto code i think at the time
that was a similar kind of idea
there were a variety of kinds of
approaches i mean
um
uh that came in
around around the same time of kind of
how would you translate some high-level
description into machine code the thing
that is sort of shocking
is that some of the operations like
loops and so on and and uh conditionals
all those kinds of things really didn't
change
from then until now from the very
beginning the dawn of kind of electronic
computing in the 1950s late 1950s to
today
most programming languages still work in
terms of loops and variables and and
arrays and so on very much the same as
those very first languages used i i
think our own wolfram language
system is is one of the very few
exceptions i mean our objectives are
much broader than sort of the pure
programming objective um but the uh the
notion that one can sort of think about
computation not in terms of variables
and loops and so on and is a is uh it's
it's it's been sort of bizarre this kind
of accident of history that the very
first computers had their very first
compilers that worked that way and it's
been sort of translated ever ever since
now the first time when people
um
started to try and make
a more formal description of kind of the
language that computers were programmed
in i think was algol um and uh
oh gosh when was the first algol
specification i think
1960 maybe i'll go 60 if i remember
right
um and so algol the idea was that this
would be a sort of precisely
mathematically defined language
um that was going to be used to program
computers
and it made use of this thing called
bacchus now a form
that had been invented around 1956 i
think
um
that was this kind of recursive
definition of a language that says you
know
a a possible expression in the language
can be
an expression plus an expression or it
can be open for an expression closed
paren this kind of recursive description
of a language um that
could be given and that was kind of the
origination
of um
uh
of of of sort of what became the
specification for algol
now very curiously right around the same
time um as as bacchus and now i'm making
that up around 1956
um noam chomsky was inventing kind of
generative grammars um that have been i
think um
uh
somehow as a person called zelig harris
who was also involved in kind of a sort
of notion of formalization of languages
and formalization of description of
languages
and i i have been very curious how these
things landed both at the same year so
to speak um this sort of approach to
making specifications of computer
languages and approach to making a
description of human languages and i
asked donald trump steve this question
once i didn't get a terribly useful
answer um i think uh and i actually
recently asked somebody else
who
um
gave me a little bit more of an answer
to that question
um
but uh
i'm not quite sure which came first or
whether it was sort of a convergent
evolution kind of thing but in 1956 both
of these things kind of landed um now
people go back and say actually there
were descriptions from much longer ago
that looked like this i mean when
the typical grammar book
um
that and grammar books that existed
since antiquity there were latin and
greek grammar books
certainly latin grammar books from roman
times
um
the uh
but those grammar books
tend to be set up in a little bit of a
different way
um
although they they definitely have sort
of tables of what you can do so to speak
um but not so much this kind of
recursive description of a sentence is a
this and a phrases of that and and so on
recursively going down
people have often said that panini who
was a grammarian of sanskrit
from around uh well a couple thousand
years ago now um
possibly longer than that it's not not
very easy to date
um
that uh he had sort of a
they i don't know whether it knows
but that person had um
uh
um
a description of um
uh
um
uh
of of the grammar of sanskrit in the
sort of recursive form
um i did look at
the the actual um originals of that
recently and it's pretty hard to
understand obviously it's not written in
i can't read sanskrit it was originally
written in sanskrit so i'm looking at a
translation which already is difficult
but it feels more like kind of aphorisms
that just say things like
you know a sentence has a verb in the
middle
they don't say things as abstract as
that they're a little bit more example
based so it's it's it's pretty hard to
tell sort of exactly how that history
connects
um but anyway algol uh algol 60 i think
um developed um uh the sort of formal
description and i'm afraid as has
happened a few times in the history of
um
of computing it was a big committee that
that invented this whole algol
specification
and uh i'm sure that people were adding
all these pieces about yes we should
have it have this functionality and that
functionality and in the end it wasn't
really implemented completely and i
remember when i first used a computer in
1973 or so
there was supposedly a sort of algol
like language it was called sympol which
was a simple version of algol um that
was more or less completely supported on
that computer but algol was like still
way
in the in the stratosphere of something
way too complicated to actually support
um so i think that's a little bit of the
history of those things now the concept
of writing a compiler for a language in
the language itself
was something which was certainly
somewhat understood i would say
uh well certainly by the 70s
um and
the
the actual doing of that
uh
probably
i wonder what the first
compilers that were written in the
language itself actually were probably
the compiler for c which must have been
1976-ish time frame um
seven maybe uh
i suspect that was written in c um the
original compiler for that as as part of
the
the c language was developed um by um
uh
uh
ken thompson dennis ritchie at bell labs
um i knew those people uh back in the
day um
the uh
that
uh that was developed originally
for uh the unix operating system which
was being developed at bell labs for
among other things telephone switching
applications
um i mean dennis ritchie actually had
had
written his thesis i think about things
called register machines which are a
simple model of computation and it's
kind of a little charming i've never
really traced it through completely the
extent to which the very lovely minimal
sort of syntax of c
um derives from the actual sort of
formal description of register machines
i mean c as a language uh sort of a
derivative of bcpl they've been a
language called b also and that was c
was sort of the next in line in in the
things derived from that
let's see
uh
well aaron is asking about the history
of computer graphics standards and
libraries
such as opengl and so on well i know
some of this i'm not sure i know it
completely
the
the first kind of
first computer graphics things
okay back in the day oscilloscopes were
basically the output for graphical kinds
of things
and you would have you know the dot on a
cathode ray tube and you would sort of
make the dot dance around
and there were so-called storage scopes
which had phosphors that had very long
uh uh delay uh decay times so you the
spot would run around on the screen and
you could sort of draw something by
having that spot uh just by sort of
keeping the the um where the spot would
be
and i think things like the pdp one
um had
those kinds of displays that must have
been um
1961-2
something like that had those kinds of
displays and early
uh well
both
early um uh air defense computer was was
based on those kinds of things i think
and its display was based that way i
think some air traffic kinds of things
worked that way very first you know the
space war computer game i think worked
that way
so those were sort of very early
computer graphics where you just in a
storage scope now when i started using
computers uh and making graphical things
with computers there were basically two
technologies
um one was uh
uh one was essentially storage scopes
uh a little bit generalized by that time
company tektronix had made uh sort of uh
terminals that also had this kind of
graphical character to them that was
kind of like oscilloscopes and and they
would typically you'd be able to print
from that um
uh
print from the display by using
essentially a thermal a photographic
printing process you'd have the display
and you press a button and there'd be
the sort of
photographic like paper that came out
that um that had kind of an image of
what was on that display that was
technology number one was kind of the
cathode ray tube oscilloscope
type technology uh technology number two
was pen plotters
um and i for example used this must have
been 1976.
um i used a pen plotter
that was uh hp had a very nice um
desktop uh
calculator slash computer um used a kind
of a version of the basic programming
language um and it had a pen plotter and
so a pen plotter you're moving sort of x
and y directions and moving the pen
around and i think it had um it even had
several different pens so you could make
um plots with different colors and so on
so those were two of the early
technologies people used
now
subsequently
this notion of a bitmap display that is
a display where there is a piece of
memory that stores values in it and
where there is a display that is kind of
a a copy of what's in memory um so that
you can get this whole raster of data on
the on the display um that's something
that i think probably existed by the
early 70s
at the at the latest i think the first
time i saw one of those
was probably at xerox park the xerox
palo alto research center
probably around 1970
perhaps
absolutely no it must have been 1979 i
think
um
uh where
there was both um
uh
both displays that were bitmap displays
and um
uh
that were um
um
oh i should have explained yeah i mean
in
early let's see i'm now
uh the early computers like the uh
uh the atari and the apple
apple ii and things like that
um they had a display where you could uh
you could specify the the um the pixels
on the screen but they were pretty low
resolution the things that xerox park
for example were very high resolution
high enough resolution that you could
form letters uh for example by the by by
just the dots in the letter being
directly rendered to the screen before
that in cathode ray tubes there were
so-called character generators which
were separate kinds of things where for
example you would physically have the
electron beam go through a metal uh kind
of template a metal um uh sort of
thing that would make kind of a
silhouette of the beam
to produce those letters rather than
having it be that the letters were
formed by
actually uh constructed sort of pixel by
pixel on the screen that was kind of the
new thing there i remember actually um
back when i first visited xerox park
there was also a color laser printer
which was also a completely um uh you
know technology that didn't really
reappear elsewhere for quite a while
um but then
in terms of of computer graphics
and i may have my dates slightly
scrambled um evans and sutherland was a
company based in utah that was
a um
an early computer graphics
company that
invented quite a lot of
the kind of the methods for rendering 3d
objects and so on um i you know i'm i'm
trying to remember all these pieces of
history because i i um there are lots of
lots of individual parts there was a
company called triple i information
international incorporated based in los
angeles that have been started
co-founded by a friend of mine named ed
fritkin
and that was founded in the early
beginning of the 1960s did lots of
different things including sort of
producing
some very early computer graphics
for uh for for example television
productions i think they produced the um
uh the the cbs spinning logo um as a
computer simulated thing
um
but uh you know there have been pieces
like that
um there's
gosh there are there's so many different
parts to all of this um but i think
the uh
uh the way that um
that sort of some of the modern uh
graphics standards emerged
the uh
i don't know completely the lineage of
this but somehow out of evans and
sutherland came various companies
including silicon graphics
which was a company that made very
beautiful purple computers and things
that was back in the
mid to late 1980s
and
sgi silicon graphics one of its
specialties was having it be the case
that you could take a 3d geometry and um
uh and have it rendered on the computer
and spin it around and do all those
kinds of cool things and it had special
purpose circuitry that allowed you to do
those kinds of things and i think
gradually that sort of special purpose
circuitry methodology
gave way to
uh these libraries like
gl i'm not sure there were a couple of
companies there was one called ardent
and one called stella which were sort of
mini supercomputer-ish companies that
came into existence um right around the
time mathematica was first released in
1988 those companies were very much
those two companies were very much
duking it out in the kind of small
graphics oriented super computer-ish
type machines uh strangely they were
eventually merged into a emerged company
called stardont that was stellar and
ardent put together
but um i think some of these graphics
standards um were developed by those
guys as well
um and uh
it sort of gradually went from oh you
need all the special purpose hardware
as has happened throughout the history
of computing to well actually with
slightly better algorithms and so on and
faster general computers you can just
use generic cpus to do all the
computations
one of the things that's confusing is
that back in the well the 80s for
example um people were producing all the
time we're producing these kind of
special purpose code processors where
it's like you've got your cpu but then
you also need the fpu that's the
floating point unit or you also need the
special
arbitrary precision arithmetic floating
point in it or you need the special uh
thing that does this or that kind of
operation
and
the the typical experience was that by
the time you really got those things up
and running
cpus because of the greater economic
pressure on just make generic computing
faster had gotten to the point where
with with a bit of clever algorithm work
you could sort of outperform the special
purpose devices with the general-purpose
ones and so for many of those things
that you know for a while we were
supporting a variety of kind of special
purpose co-processor devices
in in early versions of mathematica and
so on and then eventually we got kind of
cynical about it because it's like every
time we go to all the effort to do this
a year later oh there's just a library
that's a pure software library that does
the same kind of thing and there wasn't
even any reason to go to all the work to
support all the drivers and things like
that
i kind of suspected the same thing would
happen with gpus
um but it hasn't and it probably won't
at this point that sort of everything
that was a gpu functionality would kind
of fall back into what a cpu could do
and what compilers could handle
uh generating code for but that isn't
what's actually happened and i think the
modern gpus which are much more
vectorizing oriented things than they
are specifically the kind of graphics
processing uh uh world but but um they
were used for that and that's kind of um
again sort of things are hardwearizing
well it's more complicated because
they're libraries that make use of gpus
and so on that make use of special
hardware but their interface is a pure
software interface i should say that
sort of what enabled computer graphics
um
really was the developments of numerical
linear algebra which was something that
really happened in the 1960s and so on
people
had been thinking how do you find the
inverse of a matrix
well you know people knew how to do it
by hand it started to be relevant to
know how to do it on computers by the
beginning of the 1960s
and there was sort of slow development
of oh they're these different techniques
which were crazy if you were going to do
them by hand but were really good if you
were doing them systematically on a
computer various kinds of decomposition
of matrices that made it easier to
invert them those kinds of things and
and sort of it became clear that for
example the obvious way to multiply two
matrices together which takes uh what is
it order n cube time to to work out the
the products of the matrices um you can
uh there's a lot of sort of repeated
operations that get done there and you
can gradually speed that up
um that that isn't what and and
gradually there are sort of different
algorithmic techniques some of those
algorithmic techniques end up being a
bit infeasible for even matrices that
are thousands of uh rows and columns and
so on or even uh up to millions of rows
and columns they're theoretically
interesting but not yet in practice
interesting but the developments of
numerical linear algebra which got more
and more standardized and more and more
kind of burnt into at least very low
level libraries
um was part of what enabled the
possibility of computer graphics and
particularly 3d rendered graphics and so
on i mean back when
when we were first developing
uh mathematical or from language
well okay so we had
an smp
the system that i developed from 1979 to
about
1982-83-ish
we had 3-d graphics
and those were produced how were they
produced
in the end they were rendered
on things like these tektronix devices
and did they had hidden surface removal
hidden surface removal is the big thing
that is you draw a surface
and there are parts that in a real
surface a physical sort of solid surface
you can't see through you can make a
wire mesh or you just make a mesh
surface you're just drawing the grid
lines and that you can make rather
easily and that's because you just need
to know the coordinates of all those
things you need to do the perspective
transformations and so on but you can
easily draw that but it's much more
difficult when you want to do hidden
surface elimination
actually we did have that in smp i think
it was done using a z buffer technique
where you basically say let's draw out
the every piece of every line let's draw
it at a particular xyz pixel position
and you're just going back from the
front woods from the back just saying
which pixels can you see
when we built this for for wolfen
language and mathematica starting in 87
we wanted to do resolution independent
hidden surface removal hidden surface
elimination and that was much harder
because we were using as our graphics
description language we were using
postscript which is a resolution
independent uh language for defining
graphics saying you know put this
polygon here put this line here and so
on and we wanted to do that
for
uh
for 3d graphics
and um
that was um
uh that that was much more challenging
and required a much more algorithmic
approach of figuring out oh this polygon
that goes here obscures this part of
that polygon here and you know when you
have polygons in front of each other
they will often shatter the polygons
behind them you have to break them up
into lots of pieces and that was
algorithmically quite tricky
let's see there's a question here from
word nerd
about the history of wikipedia how did
it come to exist
i certainly don't know all the details
of that
um
i know
i remember going to
an event
oh gosh when was this this must have
been
[Music]
2002 2003
at which
somebody was showing off was it
at mit and somebody was showing off
sort of the wikipedia thing
and it was something where they had a
little thing that chirped every time an
edit was made to the um to the system
and it was chirping quite quite rarely
actually and the person who was showing
me this
was uh proudly showing that there was a
page about me on on wikipedia and um
asked me whether it was correct and i
think it was more or less correct with a
few errors and that person then went and
edited the things that were wrong and
and there was a chirp and and off it
went
um
i think uh the subsequent history well i
know
from having talked to jimmy wales long
time ago um who was the uh
um
uh
sort of the the person the force behind
wikipedia
um
the uh i know that our math world
website um was one of the kind of
inspirations for kind of the general uh
sort of presentation of wikipedia and
i'm afraid
well then people sucked content out of
mathworld and put it on wikipedia um
eric weinstein who's the person who
originally created math world um i had
been persuading trying to persuade him
for a long time to accept sort of other
people's contributions and it was a
challenge because eric is a
person with high standards and most
other people's contributions didn't
quite meet his standards so that was
sort of a challenge is how do you make
this kind of group um
activity uh work and maintain standards
and so on i know jimmy wales originally
had a project called newpedia which was
an attempt to sort of make
a um
uh
make an encyclopedia for the web let me
let me go back to a little bit about
other things that i that i know so you
know the whole world of encyclopedias um
had been started by people like dellen
bear in the 1700s in um in paris
um and uh
then encyclopedia britannica
was founded in edinburgh
where was that sometime in the 1700s and
in secondary britannica had kind of
defined
uh in the english language at least this
notion of what is an encyclopedia and
people
had uh
um you know it had gradually grown i
mean i certainly have a facsimile copy
of the the first edition which is a
small you know maybe three inch spine
four inch spine book um that was kind of
almost like an expanded dictionary um of
of concepts and uh
and so on and that was kind of the
defining uh version of what an
encyclopedia should be the encyclopedia
britannica gradually grew i have a copy
for example the 1911 encyclopedia
britannica which is so i don't know uh
well a solid shelf of books the 1911 one
was particularly famous because it's one
where the editors of the encyclopedia um
got
lots of people like einstein and so on
to write articles about things and it
was very celebrity written encyclopedia
um and it really it had a um a sort of a
um
had quite a lot of long articles about
some about things i think maybe einstein
wrote the one that light perhaps
um but in any case
the um there was some uh sort of
encyclopedia britannica developed as a
as a business
it developed in a certain way
and um it ran into all kinds of problems
i think it was sold for a dollar um at
least twice in its existence um it
somehow came into the orbit of the
university of chicago um and uh uh which
i think owned it for a while um and uh
through that
uh it came into the influence of a
person called mortimer admiral adler who
was a philosopher at university of
chicago who was a person who had sort of
theories about um
about the theory of knowledge and so on
and so he
uh was quite um influential in kind of
the the i think he even became the
editor of the inside the britannica and
he eventually decided to sort of
refactor how the encyclopedia worked
into what he called the macropedia and
the micropedia the micropedia was kind
of almost dictionary style you know
quick hits on different topics and the
macropedia was sort of more essay-based
kind of pieces and i think he had a
thing called the propedia which was kind
of a a an ontological kind of a map of
all knowledge
i remember looking at that um that
document actually oh gosh this takes me
back
when i was working on snp
around 1980
i kind of had the idea of making kind of
this
kind of computational knowledge type
system of having that time sort of
packages that would represent different
kinds of uh human knowledge and so on
and um uh represent those things
computationally and i remember um
getting out a copy of that propedia uh
kind of part of the incentive britannica
as a kind of an attempt to have a map of
human knowledge um to kind of say what
would be the categories of thing that we
would need to implement at that time
didn't get implemented had to wait for
another
oh what was it 30 years or so
for the development of kind of waltham
alpha and our whole sort of
computational language story um but that
was uh there was a time that was
encyclopaedia britannica had this sort
of map of knowledge and had these kind
of different levels that mata madala had
defined for the encyclopedia but um
meanwhile encyclopedia britannica as a
as a kind of a a as a business
was kind of a funny thing because it had
been sold to schools and universities
and things like that
um but uh it also was sold to
individuals and families and so on and
it had a very uh
direct sales kind of approach it had
actual sales people who would go out and
try and you know sell you an
encyclopedia and and sometimes it was
sort of an interesting type of person
who would become an encyclopedia
salesman um uh because it was kind of a
you know you're selling knowledge in a
sense it's rather a rather a nice thing
actually um i remember oh years later oh
this is a a strange footnote to history
but um there was a a a
a um a very californian kind of movement
called est
um that was started by chap who went by
the name of werner erhard it was i think
asked something or other training um was
that was the the thing it was kind of a
self-improvement kind of um uh well some
people call it self-improvement some
people would call it a cult
there was a disagreement about that but
anyway this chap werner erhard
took it upon himself this must have been
1979 1980 to start organizing
conferences about theoretical physics
um and i happened to be invited to one
of these when i was um uh quite young
and um
the um
as a smallish group of physicists
um and another person who was there was
it was dick feynman um and somehow
uh the the assembled group of physicists
that kind of uh chosen dick feynman and
myself to be the people who would you
know be be the ones talking to werner
earhart at this uh fancy dinner that was
um that was uh being had at this
conference and sort of the at the time
of course the web didn't exist wikipedia
didn't exist you know knowing the
history of werner earhart was not an
easy thing to to determine um and so i
spent some early part of the dinner
determining that and and i was very
interested to find out that he'd been an
encyclopedia salesman and in fact his
kind of way of approaching sort of
explaining the world and so on was was
very charmingly uh kind of
you know what you would do to explain
fragments of knowledge um to uh
at the time i mean you know in today's
world that sounds kind of silly because
people say oh you want some fragment of
knowledge well just go look it up on the
web but back before the web you want
some fragment of knowledge where would
you find it well you would find it in an
encyclopedia
and and that was a thing that people
needed to be sold on the idea that it
was useful to have an encyclopedia i
have to say that i when i first sort of
was exposed to encyclopedia britannica
um i i looked up a few things that were
relevant to uh
to science that i was doing and i wasn't
very impressed and so for years
afterwards i kind of ignored the
encyclopedia and um only many years
later when i when i uh sort of i think
the particular areas i had looked up
have been particularly uh thin in the
encyclopedia for whatever reason but for
for some time this must have been um
oh late 80s i just wanted to get myself
a copy of the encyclopedia and so i was
like
like okay you can i got somebody to call
and say you know can we buy one you know
how much they cost and it's like no no
we'll send a sales person around to tell
you about it it's like no we just want
to buy it
and so i was finally i was at um this
must have been in uh
1993-ish i was finally
at a
book fair street book fair in chicago
and there was an encyclopedia britannica
booth by the way uh inside of britannica
was based in chicago then as as now
um and uh
i thought finally there's a street booth
where they are selling encyclopedia
britannica i can just buy one and you
know i lived in the chicago area at that
time put it in a box take it home i'm
done no more you know let's send a sales
person out
and it was a huge challenge to actually
buy the thing it was like look i can
write you a check i can give you a
credit card i actually just want to buy
it how much does it cost and i think the
answer was like
maybe 1500 something of that of that
order um but
i the the salesperson
uh just wouldn't sort of let me escape
and actually buy the thing without going
into this huge song and dance and speech
and so on and so on and so on which was
uh it was kind of interesting but but
that was subsequently quite a business
problem for the encyclopedia because
that direct sales model which had a very
elaborate commission structure and so on
uh didn't really survive the transition
to electronic times
uh actually a friend of mine was a
consultant for instability britannica
who really tried to convince them to
make a sort of more open uh web visible
encyclopedia but that didn't work out at
the time
meanwhile there was another
encyclopedia uh
which was well let's see there were two
other things there was some
uh the effort to make a sort of online
encyclopedia a thing called encarta
which was done by bill gates at
microsoft and they bought i think the
funk and wagnalls encyclopedia if i
remember correctly um and uh tried to
make kind of a
a a computerized version of that
and it was an interesting product um was
a commercial failure and it was a you
know i think it was at the time
let's see it must have had cd-roms must
have been right at the time when
uh there was a transition from
distributing software on floppy disks to
distributing software on cd-roms
because you couldn't really have fit
the um the data for an encyclopedia onto
floppy disks that would have been an
absurd number of floppy disks i remember
for in carter there were things like
encoding the images they were using a
very elaborate fractal based imaging
coding scheme that um i think uh chat
called michael barnsley had been
involved in in developing um that was
based on iterative function systems and
it's kind of a precursor of wavelet
based image compression but done a
different way but because the goal in in
in carter was just like we've got to get
some pictures in there but we've got to
get them as small as possible to fit on
a cd-rom so that they can actually be
used but that was sort of an early um
computerized encyclopedia not a
commercial success
um i think jimmy wales wanted to do sort
of a commercial version of that you know
had web 3 and so on existed and or had
tim berners-lee decided that the web
should have micro payments from the very
beginning the history of encyclopedias
on the web might have been very
different from from the way it actually
turned out the original kind of
commercial version of uh jimmy wales
vision did not work out
and um there's a chap
oh my gosh what's his first name sanger
i guess is his last name and i certainly
met him even fairly recently um oh my
gosh don't remember his first name um
sorry
uh
who
was kind of a more of a philosopher of
knowledge type person who was involved
in the early sort of conceptualization
of wikipedia
but um wikipedia kind of became this
kind of um crowdsourced thing
um i think
it's some a um
uh jimmy wales certainly told me that he
he felt he'd completely lost lost
control of what was happening with it
and wasn't entirely happy with what was
happening with it i do remember this
must have been
93 94 time frame going to a conference
in boston called wikimania which was i
think one of the very early maybe the
first
uh kind of whether they still exist
um wikipedia conferences and it was
really quite interesting because a lot
of people who'd been sort of editing
wikipedia showed up at this conference
and they'd never met each other and it
was very curious collection of people
because it was a lot of people who were
very diverse collection of people in
terms of their kind of
occupational backgrounds and so on
from you know some professor types
to uh a lot of sis and many type people
some librarians
uh some people who were uh kind of like
well i could i you know i just started
editing wikipedia and it was it was fun
and uh it's like they didn't have you
know they were basically you know going
from encyclopedia britannica and
reference books and so on and entering
some of that material into wikipedia and
and using mathworld actually which by
that time existed as a as a website um
and uh uh and you know transferring its
material into wikipedia i don't know in
in modern times uh i'm i'm um i think
most people probably uh you know when i
when i look at wikipedia pages about
people i figure the person who the page
is about wrote this page because uh uh
in most cases i i have to say i've i've
avoided reading my own wikipedia page
um i i think i'm not as necessary to
to produce such a page about because
i've written an awful lot of stuff about
um
and said an awful lot of stuff about my
own history and uh if the world wants to
have a decent version of a page about me
there's a ton of material to use to uh
to make that and um somehow i i think i
have been uh
it's been part of my approach to things
to uh uh to not read stuff other people
write about me because i feel it's a
it's not a useful it's kind of like a uh
you know video feedback system or
something it's not one of these things
where
you end up getting them uh it ends up
not being a not being a useful loop i
have to say i i am i think some of the
things for example for the nks book um
should be on wikipedia i don't know if
they actually are but but um it's
something where uh for people to take
chunks of stuff from the nks book where
where i have pretty good summaries of
lots of kinds of
uh lots of kinds of ideas particularly
in the notes and so on um i do notice
with great regularity that the things
that are on wikipedia are distinctly
worse than the things that you could get
by just lifting a paragraph and quoting
it from the from the nks book um and uh
but i don't know the the the processes
for getting that to happen maybe maybe
folks who
who listen to these live streams could
uh could do the world of service and um
uh
and and uh make use of those kinds of
things
and i think um at some point in the past
uh
we set it up so that a bunch of pictures
that we make are usable in wikipedia in
terms of their licenses and so on and i
i guess that that got some of them to be
used although i don't i don't know how
many i think that this process of having
kind of a a crowd-sourced place
um
you know wikipedia has been very
successful in many ways um i think
sometimes when you dig into details it
kind of falls apart
but um uh the um
overall i think it's been a tremendously
successful thing it's always interesting
to me to see which of these kinds of uh
crowd-sourced
things are doable and which are not i
mean one general one general rule is if
it's been done before
then it can be done again perhaps better
by kind of a a crowd-sourced approach
um you know encyclopedia britannica
already existed so you could make a kind
of online version of that or an
amplification of that because there was
sort of a pattern for how to do it i
mean britannica as an organization
um we've interacted with them uh
repeatedly over the years
um it's kind of a a sad story because
they had had quite a large curation
effort of people uh sort of um uh sort
of maintaining a few hundred people
maintaining the encyclopedia and they
they had a lot of issues because they
were printing encyclopedia and they were
you know printing a new addition every
year and so on and so there were a lot
of issues about well wait a minute if we
change that page it will have a ripple
effect that will affect all these
subsequent pages so when we make a
change about this thing we have to make
sure that it keeps the same space or
doesn't ripple through too many pages
otherwise we have to re re
redo you know a thousand pages or
something in that volume of the
encyclopedia so they had a lot of issues
like that they had also tried to set up
an internal database of uh kind of
knowledge which um at various times we
we
interacted with them about using but i
think in the end it's pretty tiny
compared to what we had to build for
alpha for example um and i think it it
um
but it was sort of an interesting
example i think probably based on what
my adela's kind of ideas about um uh
sort of uh
constructs that um
uh the way of of of breaking down
knowledge into pieces i think notions of
singulars things of which there's one of
it versus collective things and so on um
things like this and and um uh sort of
relationships between uh between uh
objects and so on and i i don't think we
ever actually i don't think i ever
actually saw the the real sort of pure
um kind of representation
of uh of what insights peter britannica
had um but they had a very state of the
art kind of operation going with very
good curation um which unfortunately was
just not uh not commercially viable um
after sort of the web
uh and uh the transition to the web
really just didn't work very well um and
then wikipedia came along and and that
effort uh kind of uh kind of
died off
um i think it's um
uh it's interesting as i say what
is accessible to sort of this proud
approach i mean for example one thing we
certainly notice
is wikipedia is a great source of kind
of folk information like what are the
typical names by which something is
known that's an important thing for us
for natural language understanding for
from alpha when it comes to sort of raw
systematic data that you can compute
from that's a quite different story
because you know the the crowd so to
speak will tend to put in a thing maybe
they'll come from one source originally
and somebody would just copy a bunch of
stuff from that source
copyright be damned or whatever but um
uh the um into wikipedia but then
they'll gradually people will say no no
that that value i got a better version
of that and so gradually what was
something quite systematic um will
become something um
that uh is is no longer systematically
computable from um and so that's uh uh
that that's sort of a different
objective um that that one can have
now i think um it's interesting to see
these different kinds of projects that
work and don't work
uh you know another one started by a
friend of mine named steve cost his open
street map which was a very successful
project uh that was steve costa actually
had been an intern at our company back
when he was in
high school i guess
um
and um had
then uh uh at some point gotten very
frustrated he was based in england he
got very frustrated about the ordnance
survey um
uh and um uh ordnance survey was the as
the government mapping uh organization
that puts out maps in the uk and um they
were like no no these maps are very
proprietary and you can't um uh can't
openly make use of them on the web and
elsewhere and um steve decided he was
just gonna
launch a kind of a crowd source project
to just map the world
and
a tremendously successful project
certainly helped by the fact that gps's
came in and people could start just
driving routes and uploading things from
gps's and annotating maps and so on and
i it's been
i think it also helps that in a
geographic setting there are you know
somebody can decide i really want to see
the maps be right for costa rica and you
know i'm going to make you know really
put an effort into um uh
into making that happen and become the
sort of person in charge of of that that
kind of mapping i i know in that
particular case i ran into the person
who was in that particular role who had
been i think working for the postal
service in costa rica where they had
tremendous trouble from from streets
badly named and misnamed and renamed and
so on and just decided you know use the
openstreetmap framework and just get the
things straightened out and uh you know
i don't i don't can't speak to the
precise quality of what was done there
but but um that was sort of a general um
uh kind of uh impression of of what was
what was going on but that's a place
where you know maps had existed
obviously um but this was a place where
one could take sort of the crowd and um
uh and in that case kind of um uh
organize it in some cases rather
regionally to produce a high quality uh
sort of street map of the world
um i think um
uh this whole question of sort of what
happens to these communities and
particularly the originators of these
communities um how are they
uh you know at what point do they sort
of lose control of the of the collective
creature that they've produced and the
answer is i think fairly early um the
the versions of this that are successful
that usually happens and it's actually a
very if you were to say you know is it a
good career move to start one of these
things if you want to feel satisfied in
the end well it's good if you are
satisfied by the fact that the thing you
launched becomes a big thing in the
world it's very unsatisfying if you care
about the thing you launched uh
operating ways in ways that you thought
it should operate or that the people who
are operating it kind of um uh
think more of you than just it's a sort
of originating guru so to speak it's one
of these things where um yeah people say
well it's it's uh uh it's a sort of
cautionary tale in terms of
crowdsourcing kinds of things
um
but that's uh
that's what i know about that i think
um
let's see
uh
ah somebody's reminding me it's larry
sanger apologies larry
um i i know um uh
larry has been interested in some
uh blockchain related encyclopedia
projects and we've
interacted about those kinds of things
um i think
you know i will say by the way that
there is a lot of opportunity
for
other
ways of communicating knowledge and and
sort of encyclopedic knowledge one of
the things i've long wanted to do
is to take our sort of computational
essay uh kind of format
and produce
a kind of uh
an exposition project
just expositions about all kinds of
things in a mixture of human language
and computational language so that one
is not only just reading the narrative
but also able to actually compute from
uh
from the things that are written on the
page and and i've done that to a certain
extent and certainly one of the things
i've taken as a principal for the last
few years in writing things about
science and so on is that every picture
in every piece that i write you should
be able to click on it and get the world
from language code that you can run
anywhere to to compute with
you know i have to say that i i feel
like what we've got in world language
and our sort of effort to make a
computational language that can describe
everything computationally i think it is
finally a good way of making raw
material for sort of representing
knowledge computationally and i feel
pretty good about the fact that i can
pick up kind of pieces of work and
language code from 35 years ago and run
them today that's a that's a good sign
that um we didn't make um compromises
that are kind of going to you know over
that span of time we've dealt with a lot
of change in kind of the world of
computing um and yet uh the the the that
um the the kind of the principles there
and the actual code still runs and i
think we can expect that to continue um
into the into the sort of infinite
future because it's one of these cases
where what we defined what i defined was
a language which was defined for its own
sake not a language which was defined
for the purpose of fitting into the
particulars of the computer hardware of
1987 or something um and so that's
something which like mathematics
like uh sort of formal kinds of systems
is something which is time is timeless
and so you can expect can be preserved
and and can keep running into the future
we have never had that before we've had
in the 1600s people talked about sort of
philosophical languages as a way to
represent knowledge independent of human
languages that was a thing leibniz john
wilkins people like that wrote about
this um but they didn't have the the
material they didn't have computers they
didn't have the the internet the web you
know ways to communicate knowledge
things like this which we have today
and finally i think we have um well
after the 40 years i've put into it we
have kind of a a language for
representing knowledge computationally
um and i think there's a sort of a great
opportunity to build sort of the next
level of encyclopedia-like thing
as something which is represented in
computational language it's very
important that you actually have a
computational language it's not going to
work if you're writing things with
programming language because programming
language doesn't have a representation
of a city or even a graph or an image
those are things not part of the
programming language as such but they're
things you need as the raw material to
sort of talk about things
computationally if you want to get far
and talking about them so i think we
sort of have a unique opportunity now um
that uh to sort of build the next level
of these kinds of things and and i've
been sort of trying to kind of define
how to get that started for a while and
and um it's one of those projects which
um uh is a
project one would one would like to see
done but it's a challenge to do
i think you know we we started something
like that with our demonstrations
project back in the mid 2000s um it's
been quite successful now i don't know
13 000 or so of these runnable uh
demonstrations uh you know in in
notebooks and on the web um of all kinds
of things demonstrations are more for
their sort of visual effect to run the
slider and see this see this um
and understand how to uh how some
particular thing works more so than for
the code inside them which basically at
this point is is that if the code works
and produces the the thing you want
that's great but i think what's
important about computational essays is
the use of code the use of computational
language as an actual piece of
exposition just like mathematical
formulas can be used as a as a sort of
piece of exposition that's an
opportunity to do that and that's sort
of a new possibility that that um exists
today
um that uh uh is it sort of different
from the kind of thing you find in the
traditional encyclopedia to wikipedia
type thing which is more of a narrative
where you uh you know which is intended
for people to just read um as opposed to
something where you can expect to build
on it explicitly rather than just have
it go into your brain and and then
you learn from it
all right i i should uh
wrap up
um
soon here there's some comments some
uh alistair's commenting that hp 9800s
were awesome
um
uh
okay they had overlapping video memories
one was ascii character-based the other
was hp plotter language control wow i i
think that the um
the pen plotter
output
desktop calculator thingy
that i used was a nine something or
other
hp device but it didn't have that same
it didn't have a
a um
the only display it had was um
oh my gosh what are those um
it was beyond uh there were seven
segment displays which are made from
light emitting diodes from an array of
of sort of uh vitamin diodes in the
shape of an eight
um but then there were fancier versions
of that that could display
uh sort of um lots of characters um as
these kind of uh miniature bitmap
displays just sort of uh a ticker tape
one character at a time um and i think
that's the kind of uh thing that that
that had along with probably a thermal
printer that printed a little strip of
paper actually that's a good question
but i still have programs i must have
programs that i wrote on that machine i
i i did a bunch of physics calculations
on that machine um and uh
i was kind of using at the time i was
using
um that machine and a mainframe computer
that was programmed with with um cards
and i'm trying to remember whether there
was any way of getting
um
[Music]
uh
graphical output from the mainframe at
that time not sure that there was soon
thereafter there was a company called
printronix that made dot matrix printers
and a dot matrix printer has um this so
a line printer which was kind of the the
typical output device of a mainframe
computer was something which had this
kind of um belt that went around that
had all of these sort of um um
[Music]
kind of um little things like uh font
like printing font characters they had
little little little um
uh
uh like like typewriter keys but on this
belt and it would go around and it would
it would um
actually work it would print a line at a
time
using that and i'm now forgetting quite
how that worked
um but sort of the next
technology was the dot matrix printer
where
there were
um
um
uh
which was an array of dots that would be
printed across the page and with those
uh where the characters were formed from
collections of dots
and in those um those allowed
uh some sort of primitive graphics to be
produced i i remember there used to be
even in early unixes
there was a program
that was kind of part of the operating
system i think
that provided some basic graphical
output on things like printronix
printers back in those days it was sort
of a big deal that you had to have a
separate driver for every different kind
of printer and so on because they all
accepted their data in different ways on
on serial interfaces on parallel
interfaces etc etc etc it's only later
that all these standards for
representing these things got
established i mean you know it's kind of
remarkable to me today that in vr for
example virtual reality it is it is
bizarre that to my knowledge there isn't
really a standard that's emerged for how
do you represent all this 3d imagery i
mean they're things like unity and
unreal and so on which are essentially
game engines that people use but it's
kind of crazy to be representing what is
really just 3d imagery um using a whole
game engine sort of code-based system
but for some reason uh and this is
reminds one greatly of sort of the early
days of printable graphics that um that
there weren't those kinds of standards
um
i think
the uh
well laser printers became a thing i
first got a laser printer it's made by a
company called imogen i remember
um i must have gotten that laser printer
in
[Music]
1988
um and it was a great big object
that um was probably fairly expensive
um and uh
uh
yeah no let's see i used
that's right and there have been
previous things
the same kind of technology
um that were used for example to print
uh the kinds of things that you were
going to use to photographically make
the masks for integrated circuits
and um i think there was a what was a
company versatech i think that made
printers that printed those things out
on very very wide paper i was just
reminded of this just yesterday as i was
digging through the history of the nks
book
because um uh i remember back in 1984 or
so
printing out a giant picture of rule 30
uh 2 000 generations of rule 30 which at
the time
no no i think it was that um
on this giant roll of paper uh printed
on one of these printers that was
intended for printing out uh what would
turn into masks for an integrated
circuit um and uh
uh
perhaps the circuit board but i think to
integrate circuits in any case the um
there's a high resolution printout on
some kind of photographical paper
um actually those early
laser printers always did that and they
they had them
so i'm not sure exactly how but there
was it was not on sort of ordinary
ordinary paper um but any case that that
um uh that printout um had the
interesting sort of um
uh
uh history that it was you know high
resolution print out of rule 30 so i got
to see you know what does rule 30 do
am i sort of celebrating that produces
complicated behavior from a very simple
rule
and um i remember having that printout
on the floor at this company thinking
machines corporation that that
made parallel computers and was actually
used to generate the bits that were sent
to the printer to uh to produce this
picture
and uh dick fineman and i were both
consultants to that company and dick
feinman was very interested in this rule
30
uh phenomenon and um
he had this argument for why a
particular line in this image would be a
exactly slope one quarter and so we were
kind of um going around on the floor
with these meter rules trying to measure
this thing on this picture in fact it
turns out it's not exactly 0.25 slope
it's like 0.2481 or something like that
um but any case
and
so
that particular piece of paper or at
least a copy of it
made i think probably that particular
one um i laminated years ago
and i still have it and it's this big
role of of um you know a big big role of
stuff from it it rolls up very nicely
and i was just remembering that um my
children when they were quite young
um
uh it's this big rolled up thing and so
you can go inside it and uh you know
it's it's as it's as tall as a uh
oh probably up to a three-year-old or
something or a little bit more um and it
was a source of great entertainment uh
to to sort of go inside this giant
rolled object object
um and uh uh
um
and so that so it found a this rule 30
uh printout found a good home i was just
reminded of this yesterday because i was
um uh
was was writing about the way that
graphics were produced the nks book
which was sort of a subsequent
generation of these kinds of things um
all right i think that uh i need to wrap
up here it looks like it's time for
my next responsibility my day job which
i think is also a live stream looking at
um uh having talked a bit about history
here um now i get to build a little bit
of the future
and put another few bricks into the
cathedral we've been building these last
uh four decades or so
um and uh i think if i remember
correctly it's a review about
visualization so it might be the little
bit of the future of some of the
questions that were asked here about
computer graphics i hope
so um thanks for joining me and
see you